sous cette épaisse couche de boue
l'accès à la maison de gilbert et
albertine sous l'effet des pluies
diluviennes de l'audi lavaud a déferlé
la pente avant d'être stoppé par le mur
de béton envahissantes au passage
l'intérieur des pièces pour le couple de
septuagénaires isolé impossible de se
débarrasser seul de ces tonnes de boue
pour eux la solidarité ne viendra pas du
voisinage mais d'une vingtaine de jeux
du rsm haye de leurs formateurs
[Musique]
vers 15 heures on a fini à la tombée de
la nuit
et puis attaqué ce matin beaucoup de
boulot mais quand on est au sénat
on a signé sa joie c'est difficile
[Musique]
comme ils font partie d'un dispositif
socioprofessionnelles j'en veux dire aux
patrons d'entreprises en martinique
quand je vois des jeunes comme ça ils
sont volontaires disponibles prêts à 10
ans
le res la formation la spécialité ça
s'apprend c'est pas grave exemple de la
jeunesse ça fait plaisir des jeunes
intervenants sous réquisition du préfet
ce matin froid combiné venu leur rendre
visite ils sont vraiment dans la
détresse
et si vous n'étiez pas là ils s'en
sortent pas dans le bras d'eau près
d'une semaine après les pluies qui ont
durement frappé la commune du françois
la solidarité semble toujours primordial
pour les sinistrés